her also though and I want to make sure
we get to this other aspect megyn kelly
is also now coinciding with the release
of her memoir talking about how yes
Roger Ailes the embarrassed Fox News
chief harassed her as well she was a
victim of sexual harassment at the hands
of former Fox new CEO Roger Ailes she
went on the dr. Phil show I don't know
that we very often play clips of the dr
phil show on this program but i have a
little bit of it and it is absolutely
fascinating and you'll remember that in
the wake of all sorts of women coming
out and saying you know I was also
victimized sexually harassed by roger
ailes megyn kelly was criticized for
waiting very long in the game to come
out and say you know yeah I i also am
aware of some of the stuff and etcetera
etcetera i think that that was not a
good critique of megyn kelly we know all
of the different reasons why it is
perfectly normal and common and logical
for many victims of sexual harassment
not to be overly eager to go out and to
make those allegations public that being
said she is doing it now here is a clip
from her talking to dr. Phil yesterday
were you sexually harassed by roger
ailes yes beginning with my problems
with Roger began when I was at the
company for 12 months so I was a first
year reporter and I was called up to New
York britt hume my direct manager in the
DC bureau told me i had captured the
attention of mr. ales and told me that
he wanted to see me in New York so I
went up to New York I was working in the
Washington DC bureau and I went up there
I had met with him I think once before
you know for my job interview but this
was a great moment for me because you
want to capture the attention of your
boss and he gave me a bunch of advice
you know I went into his office it gave
me a bunch of advice but the problem
with that meeting and with several that
happened over the next six months was
not only was there legitimate
professional advice but there were
grossly inappropriate comments he had
always had an inappropriate sense of
humor you know the he is not PC
and this was actually something we liked
about him I mean he's he'll crack a
dirty joke or drop a swear and so will I
I that I don't judge that you know I
don't speak the Queen's English either
as you'll see in the book there i mean
just FYI yeah by the book um many copies
but this was something different this
was specific comments about my body how
he wanted to see me and it grew more
severe over time like what was he give
me an example well like he said he knew
I must have some very sexy bras and
you'd like to see me in them that smooth
operator Roger Ailes man that could get
that gets the women every time when you
tell them I'm going to guess at what you
have in your underwear drawer at home uh
so obviously the response from from
Roger Ailes is lawyer not surprising
which is this is all bogus but the more
interesting response to me was from Bill
O'Reilly who went on CBS yesterday any
said he's not interested in making the
network look bad at all and then he
added the following on his own show
which I'll put up on the screen for you
if somebody is paying you a wage you owe
that person or company allegiance you
don't like what's happening the
workplace go to human resources or leave
I've done that and then take the action
you need to take afterward if you feel
aggrieved their labor laws in this
country but don't run down the concern
that supports you by trying to undermine
it bill oreilly seems to see this as
just sort of like a PR issue for fox and
employee relations rather than the fact
that they had a serial sexual harasser
on staff for bill o'reilly it's more
about the right positioning of how you
complain and when into who and making my
network look bad bill o'reilly seems to
see sexual harassment as a PR issue
which makes sense because it became a
major PR issue for him when he was
talking to andrea makris about it you
know pleasuring herself and all sorts of
stuff this has clearly been a big PR
issue for bill o'reilly but he doesn't
see this as an issue of sexual
harassment which is really what it is
well that's also coming from someone who
has been accused of sexual harassment
but i think what's also interesting here
is that where megyn kelly is positioned
now because she has to try and kind of
appeal
to her new lean in fan base while also
balancing that with a lot of Fox News
watchers who really hate identity
politics yeah where does that leave her
I think it's super interesting actually
I'm not a big fan of megan kelly Pat but
I think that what she is doing here the
timing of it of course is is very
susceptible to a sort of motivation of
selling books and there's no doubt she's
going to sell a lot of books for this uh
for these appearances but she's
positioned herself in a really
interesting place now where she is both
seen as the sort of commanding
up-and-coming television star but also
someone who is not going to be pushed
around even if it's about sexual
harassment by a male superior which is
not exactly a position that lots of her
fan base is super thrilled to be out in
front of and criticizing publicly and
all the allegations that she's given so
far seem to have happened right when she
started working for Fox News yeah she
continued to get promotions got uh very
generous maternity leave so yep you have
to wonder if this kind of thing
continued and she's just keeping quiet
about it there that's the other aspect
of it which is do you sort of become
immune to this when you have higher
status in the network we saw that
gretchen carlson who not as well known
as as megan kelly and not of the same uh
sort of a stature on the network seemed
to be continually subjected to this type
of thing of course Roger Ailes denies at
all at this point really no reason to
believe the denials